did leaving Neverland present like a
real dilemma for you cuz here's Michael
Jackson I'd rather not talk about that
okay yeah I've already said what I have
to say on the subject and I'd rather
stay away from the whole Michael Jackson
topic if possible well it was it wasn't
even really about him other than when
you look at other people who are whether
they're his or anybody else is perceived
victims is it hard for you to not listen
to somebody when they say hey this
happened I have to listen to somebody
because I'm the ambassador for child USA
so my point and my purpose is to take
every single abuse claim seriously now
does that mean that they're all true not
all true but when it comes to childhood
sexual abuse
90% of claims are true so therefore we
have to take it very seriously and yes
there are cases where people go after
the money and it's not necessarily true
but those cases generally come from
adults who are claiming stuff that
happened when they were younger
not in cases where kids start talking
about it in early age you heard me
talking about it at 8:18 okay I went to
the police now I was a rare exception
because at the end of the day most
people are not comfortable dealing with
it until they're much older and much
later in life so in their 50s in their
60s that that you know is the general
that's why the statute of limitations
was always set at such a young age
because they knew that people were gonna
be able to deal with it
until much later in life okay so at 55
that's when male adults finally come to
terms with the fact like hey that wasn't
okay with me that emotionally scarred me
maybe that's why my marriages haven't
been working out maybe that's why I've
been an abusive father maybe that's why
ba bla bla bla bla bla bla
because they've suddenly realized that
they hate themselves or they hate the
people that did this to them but it's
too late because you can't get their
appeal or something when you're an old
dog right you can get therapy for
something when you're young enough to
actually change it so the point is is
that what we're doing like in New York
we passed the CVA with the help of child
USA and what that did was that allowed
for the first time in New York there to
be a one-year look-back window to open
old cases and it also put forth a longer
statute of limitations in the state of
New York so we had to go fight for that
in Albany we got it passed this year it
changed in January and that's why you
saw indictments for our Kelly and
Jeffrey Epstein in the first place this
year we fighting this is it the church I
know the churches for certain statute of
limitations they're afraid it will Bank
of course do you know how much the
church's insurance people spend every
year on child molestation cases they
spent they have insurance people that go
out there and they protect them and they
spend I think it's like 70 million a
year on insurance just on insurance just
on the premium on the base of coverage
right to make sure that their priests
get to stay employed and move from
pasture to pasture from that's when you
know that there's a lot of damage that's
70 million dollars in insurance is
cheaper than actually pay right all
being the plan all states do you going
from how do you ask Allstate for
insurance and sexual yeah kids exist
that's the scary thing it exists so it
actually benefits them to have the
sexual assault because otherwise nobody
would get paid do you think in in in
guess why they move them around that's
why they don't just handle it right it's
just frustrating do you think the fact
and we won't get into Michael but my
question is about you and the fact that
you know you've been really public about
I was great friends with Michael and
there was nothing to the accusations in
my case do you think that that's
complicated because those accusations
about Michael have been around for as
long as they've been around do you think
that that becomes a complication when
you're trying to get your message across
[Laughter]
that seems a little bit of a sidewind it
kind of you know the topic no and that
speak Ned's been such a prevalent know
part of the conversation for now the
only problem is I can't go and question
the people that I would normally
probably question pretty hard if it
doesn't feel right to me because of the
fact that I'm the ambassador for child
II was it because I can't go and say
well right okay guys definitely can't be
telling the truth that's not right
because then I would be just as
tone-deaf as the rest of the people that
are ignoring everything that I'm saying
and everybody else is saying can we all
have to listen well that's the point you
are a guy who is dealt with it like
you've had it happen so as it what is
something and I know it's different with
different people because everyone's
kind of an individual but if you're
listening to any person talk about say
sexual abuse what is something that
would set off the alarm bells in your
head to go
that doesn't sound truthful or anything
like yeah like what is something that as
a person yeah you know look again I'm
not here to try and question why
somebody wouldn't be telling the truth
I'm not here to question how that
doesn't sound truthful I'm here to say
if this sounds like injustice we need to
find justice that's my job
my job is to find the path for them to
deal with their case and if if you know
they find lawyers and they report their
stuff to the police and there's a
thorough investigation and it turns out
not to be provable well then so be it it
turned out not to be provable but at
least they should have their shot they
should have their chance that's all I'm
saying what if you have a voice should
be heard one more Jim and Sam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM app